[Music]
nigeria is a country in russia
its trans-sahara gas pipeline that's
been on hold for decades is now active
africa's biggest oil producer wants to
cash in on rising gas prices as europe
looks to reduce reliance on energy from
russia
we're in the process of building a
pipeline
a gas pipeline from here
to algeria
targeting the european market
we are also
building a pipeline
from the
west african gas pipeline to morocco
also targeting europe
so what the what
the
russian and ukraine crisis has created
is additional market for our gas
he says nigeria can make up for supply
shortfalls for many european countries
but would need more of their investments
to speed up delivery
global prices of gas have soared in the
wake of the war in ukraine with europe
accusing russia of waging an economic
war
nigerian officials say many european
investors who have been pulling out
investments in fossil fuels here are
slowly coming back
the country has proven reserves of 206
trillion cubic feet of gas
now it's aiming to triple that in eight
years as interest in crude oil is waning
for decades oil companies operating here
treated gas as a nuisance capping or
flaring it
as the rest of the world struggles with
high prices and shortages nigeria burns
30 percent of its gas every year a
resource it could be capitalizing on as
developed economies look for
alternatives to russian
supplies
industry analysts say the current global
gas supply challenges are an opportunity
to grow the sector
i think we should be talking
a lot more about
you know increasing the lng um
lng opportunities that we have
i i you know done really talking about
these pipes but that seems to be what
government seems to be focused on
but the biggest challenge for nigeria is
funding it's hoping the conflict in
ukraine could give many countries a
reason to rethink their investments in
gas as a transition fuel to cleaner
energy ahmadi trees al jazeera potakota
nigeria